is joe biden abandoning
the promised public option cnbc
is now reporting that joe biden's new
american family's plan does not include
the promised expansion of medicare
eligibility and it doesn't
include a provision allowing the program
to negotiate prices directly with drug
companies
dozens of democratic lawmakers cnbc
rights have urged biden
to include these provisions in the
second piece of his economic recovery
plan
biden's plan would make permanent
premium cuts for people buying insurance
on the individual market key democrats
are aiming to include a public option
bill or create a separate one now that
joe biden
is not including it in his recovery plan
democratic senators patty murray
uh and congressman frank pallone
are going to write a bill to create a
public option
president joe biden did run on expanding
the public insurance market
but this is not in any of his plans so
far
republicans have exposed every effort
have opposed
every effort to expand government
managed health care
democrats would likely have to look at
doing this either via a budget
reconciliation bill to pass it without
republican support because you're not
going to get republican support for a
public option
or convincing joe biden to put it in one
of his plans
including possibly the american family's
plan
there are lots of democrats absolutely
furious with joe biden for not including
this and i understand that and i'm with
them now
uh you know that on this program we are
pragmatic and i would like to see the
promised public option done
now i would like to see it done last
month i would have liked to see it done
when obamacare was first put together um
i could understand if you said to me the
inclusion of the public option
will never pass if you make it part of
this bill
and so it makes sense for joe biden not
to include it i'm just not convinced of
that yet i have not seen
evidence that if democrats hold firm
and go to joe biden and say listen joe
republicans don't want the public option
okay um we're going to need to pass it
via budget reconciliation if we're to do
it outside of this
let's just include it let's just include
it now and if we do this all via budget
reconciliation then we get the public
option done
um and let's actually put republicans in
a position to vote against all of this
stuff
now the counter would be if you don't
have
all 50 democrats on board in the senate
then it's not going to pass either way
because you're not going to get a single
republican vote
so this is one of those situations where
there's truth to both sides
do i believe that if joe biden doesn't
do the public option now he never does
it
no i i think it's possible that joe
biden would try to do it later on but
why wait
why wait that there is no better time
than now to do
something and remember the public option
was the starting negotiating point with
obamacare in 2010.
should we we should have had a better
2009 whenever the negotiations started
we should have had a starting point that
was far more progressive with obamacare
uh the first thing to go was the public
option with obamacare
is it possible joe biden will do this
later but sure yeah maybe
let's just do it right now but you've
got to have all 50 democrats on board it
is not completely clear to me that you
have them
so are the criticisms fair that it
should be done now
absolutely is the criticism fair that
this is evidence biden
is permanently abandoning the public
option no we can't say that yet we're
four months into a four-year term
that being said my preference would be
to do
this right now there is no reason to
wait
unless you don't have all 50 democrats
on board you've got to fight for their
votes
you have to negotiate with them okay if
we find out
that it is three democratic senators
that don't want the public option
and were it not for them you could do
all of this via budget reconciliation i
would say you've got to bring those
three people
joe biden brags about being able to
negotiate he brags about being able to
get deals done with the other side well
get a deal done with your own side get
those three hypothetical senators who
don't want the public option in the
american families plan
bring them to the white house and
convince them negotiate
with them do the thing that you ran on
being able to do
as a a diplomat and an elected official
and a deal maker in the senate for a
long time
could it be done in three months could
it be done in six months could it be
done in 2022 or
sure but i would like to see it done
right now and until i see evidence that
it couldn't be done right now
i believe we need to continue pushing
for it to be done now many of you will
write in and say david this is pathetic
you just got to do
medicare for all many democratic
senators don't support medicare for all
and neither does joe biden medicare for
all's not going to happen right now
okay so what's on the table is can we
get um
a public option done an idea would be
get some democrats to lobby for medicare
for all in this bill
and negotiate to a public option i would
be open to that
what i don't want is something that has
no chance of passing
if that's the case we don't know that to
be the case yet if there's no chance of
passing there's no point in holding this
bill up indefinitely
but i've not seen the work done yet that
proves to me you can't force
a public option into this bill right now
if you disagree with me let me know
and we'll have more cover coverage of
this on our instagram page
which you can find at davidpakmanshow on
instagram while you're there
follow me on instagram at david.pakman
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home
it's a service called steady md they're
one of our sponsors
you take a quiz you get matched with a
licensed primary care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you i took their quiz they matched me
with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video